in this video I'm gonna show you how to
get your MacBook Air to stop running so
loud well it's constantly trying to keep
itself from overheating and these
solutions are not gonna be like my
previous ones where I water-cooled it
and I use the gel pack these are gonna
be safe permanent solutions these tips
actually apply to most Macs made within
the last few years and as a bonus you're
most likely going to gain a few extra
hours of battery life as well like most
people I was extremely excited for the
new MacBook Air that's because we have a
new keyboard that other than this laptop
it's only available in a 16 inch MacBook
Pro which is much larger heavier and
more expensive we also have twice the
SSD capacity and we have new Intel CPUs
that offer twice the cores and with
better graphics giving us much more
performance for the same price because
of this many people are choosing to go
with the new MacBook Air instead of a
pro which costs more money but there's
only one problem
Apple did not put in a good cooler into
the system which means it runs hotter
and louder now if it only did that
during super difficult tasks that might
be fine but I'm seeing this in normal
use as well for example when I open
Chrome and went to youtube and scroll
down the air hit a hundred degrees
Celsius if you have a few tabs open and
you quickly flip between them it
actually hits a hundred degrees Celsius
and then I ended up watching as 4k 60
video and not only did the MacBook Air
hit a hundred degrees Celsius within
about 10 seconds
the fans sped up to about 6,000 rpm
which is annoying and it just stay there
now I know that not that many of you are
gonna be watching 4k video on your
MacBook Air so I tested out 1080p 60
video and it still ran really hot at 90
degrees Celsius but thankfully the fans
were spinning lower my first tip is
simple
don't use Chrome now Chrome is my
favorite browser but unfortunately it is
much more Hardware intensive thus that
means you get more heat Safari on the
other hand focuses on efficiency and
that same 1080p 60 video playback at 65
degrees Celsius with the fan completely
off opening YouTube and quickly
scrolling down I hit a max of 86 degrees
Celsius instead of a hundred and then
quickly jumping through tops for twice
as long
I couldn't get it to hit over 67 degrees
Celsius instead of quickly hitting 100
so if you're not picky about web
browsers definitely use Safari but what
if you are or what if you're running
other apps or doing other things and
your MacBook Air is running hot and loud
for example what if you want to do some
light photo or video editing or what if
you're running a dedicated app for video
streaming or even downloading and
installing files and your fan is going
crazy this is where the MacBook Air
started to kill me I was playing back a
game trailer in the epic games app and
the CPU was hitting a hundred degrees
Celsius what the fan spinning up but not
being too annoying and then I started
downloading and installing for night and
at that point after about a minute the
fan was running a full blast the CPU is
at a hundred degrees Celsius and it
stayed this way for over an hour while I
downloaded the game this is absolutely
ridiculous and let me explain why this
is happening and then tell you how you
guys can help with this issue the way
until designs their CPUs especially in
the last couple of years your processor
can actually use more than double the
wattage in certain cases to get it to
run faster for example this 1.1
gigahertz processor can actually hit up
to 3.5 gigahertz and this does make this
new MacBook Air very snappy and very
quick in fact snappier than my macbook
pro but because of that it uses more
power and puts out more heat now this
isn't a bad thing by itself but when you
pair turbo boost with a poor cooling
design and apps that are very processor
and graphics intensive that leads to
this MacBook Air running hotter and
louder than a MacBook Pro now the other
reason why is that Mac OS will give you
the maximum amount of performance when
an application asks for it because
unlike Windows there are no power
options so it doesn't default in power
efficiency or balance mode so if you're
doing something that could be sped up
with more CPU or graphics power it will
actually give it as much as I can even
if that means running hot and loud you
can see in our Cinebench are 20 tests
that the MacBook Air is trying to run
the CPU as fast as possible even though
we're at a hundred resale seus and the
fans are going at almost full blast this
is where turbo boost switcher comes in
and that's a third-party app that will
turn off turbo boost and we'll stop the
CPU from trying to reach those crazy
high frequencies even when the laptop
doesn't need it
let's start off with the free version I
downloaded it installed it allowed it to
run into security settings and then
restarted and then I went ahead and
turned off turbo boost
I opened up YouTube in Chrome and then
quickly scroll down and attempts only
hit 64 degrees Celsius instead of a
hundred I then played back a 4k 60 video
which is quite demanding and the laptop
maxed out at 85 degrees Celsius and with
the fan running at its slowest speed
possible instead of a hundred degrees
running at over five thousand rpm after
a few minutes of playing back trailers
in the epic games app the CPU did not
peak above 75 degrees Celsius and the
fan was silent as soon as I turn off
turbo boost switcher you can see that
our CPU goes from China run as fast as
possible and hitting a hundred three
Celsius to running at a constant 1.1
gigahertz
with a steady decline in temps and fan
speeds resulting with a maximum
temperature of 85 degrees Celsius and a
laptop staying completely silent now
since we are limiting the power that
also means that we're limiting the
performance which is a big bummer on a
brand new powerful machine thankfully
for normal uses I didn't really notice a
difference in performance it still felt
noticeably snappier than the 2019 air
Google Chrome was still responsive when
jumping through tabs and scrolling and
even 4k 60 video playback fine the whole
system is quick and responsive and since
the CPU isn't having these massive
wattage spikes that means that you are
gonna gain a few hours of battery life I
did notice some difference in
performances with apps that need a lot
more power so I decided to rerun
Cinebench R 20 it definitely took longer
but the CPU didn't ever go higher than
70 degrees Celsius and the fan ran
silent at its lowest speed instead of
being loud and hitting 100 degrees
Celsius the end result was a score of
630 and set of 955 which is a noticeable
drop in performance putting it very
close to 2019 macbook air but keep in
mind the 2019 air has to run hot and
loud to achieve those levels of
performance
we're the new one wit turbo boost off
can do so while running completely
silent really cool and at the same time
using less power my last tip would be to
buy turbo boost switcher pro for only
$10 this will allow you to schedule when
to have turbo boost on or off or allow
it to toggle based on the app if you
have a few apps that always make your
macbook air run hot that way you can
maximize your temperature to performance
ratio of course I wish that Apple not
only upgraded the specs and the
performance of this MacBook Air but
actually put in a decent cooler into the
machine that would have made it amazing
and unfortunately they didn't and it
kind of sucks having to use third-party
software and limiting performance to get
good thermals that definitely is a
bummer but until Apple comes out with
some kind of power modes like Windows
has which also lowers your performance
but gives you better battery life and
you know less heat this is what we're
gonna have to result to doing or maybe
just wait for a MacBook Air that has a
much better cooler so thank you guys for
watching if you have any questions ask
in the comments section down below I'll
have a link to turbo boost switcher in
the video description it's not affiliate
link or anything like that I just really
like the program if you guys want to see
more videos like this one especially our
full review of the MacBook Air you guys
can click that circle above and check
out one of those two great videos right
over there this max and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]